[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
happy taco tuesday i guess it's taco
team too right
know what it is
[Music]
oh boy oh boy do we have a lot of trash
to take out today
on today's tweety tweets and trendy
trends
oh my god
the trash does not stop
the trash
the garbage
does not stop
it's endless with these [ __ ]
just they they can't quit
i had to i had to correct a jd vance um
political ad this morning i didn't
change it i didn't do any i didn't
manipulate anything
you just
cut it in the appropriate phrases that
maybe it should have been cut i don't
know
i mean i you know i didn't do any edits
it's his words
we're gonna show that then we're gonna
break down a good liars video holy
actual [ __ ] you guys thought that the
space cadet
with the space force lady you remember
this lady
who thought the space force had like i
don't know it was gonna have military
tribunals and had all the machines and
whoo you know whack-a-doo type [ __ ]
q anon whack-a-doo type [ __ ] you
remember this it was yesterday we just
showed this yesterday was at the
at the nazi rally over i mean excuse me
the trump rally over the weekend
you thought that was the craziest
[ __ ] thing you ever heard no no
no
not
no not the craziest thing you've ever
heard in your life no
there's more crazy
than
than [ __ ] space cadets with space
lasers in the space force
and
elected congresswoman
claiming that
trump
captured osama bin laden
and there was no war while trump was in
office
brain dead whack-a-doo
q anon facebook ivermectin group type
[ __ ]
yep
i said it
facebook ivermecton institute facebook
group all you out there on facebook know
what i'm talking about
because that's the rub we're now
broadcasting on facebook did you know
that we're broadcasting live on minus
touch facebook page also youtube twitter
twitch every single weekday if you're
new and you're joining us
this this [ __ ] happens every
every weekday every single one monday
through friday
it happens
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter twitch and now coming
to you from the midas touch facebook
page we're on the books of face folks
we are spreading our liberal libtard
propaganda
all over facebook
spreading it around like herpes so share
this video like it comment
and share it with one of your your trump
humping friends you know who i'm talking
about or your relative your uncle daryl
or something you know he loves trump got
a he's got a tattered trump 2020 flag
he wants putin to run with trump in 2024
if jfk jr doesn't
he's going to join the space force
to make sure that he saves america and
puts america first
speaking of america first and trump
sycophants
jd vance has a new political ad it's
fantastic by the way
oh god
jd vance
you know that [ __ ] idiot who wrote
the what is it the hillbilly effigy is
that what it's called they made the
movie somehow he he became pseudo-famous
because he wrote a stupid [ __ ] book
about how he abandoned
he abandoned rue america
for a lead america and republicans like
yeah we like that [ __ ]
he's running for senate in ohio i'm not
[ __ ] you this guy's running he used
to be anti-trump now he's for trump
he's so much for trump he's saying in
his political ads he's asking the people
who are voting for him are you a racist
do you hate mexicans
vote for me jd vance i mean he didn't
say that exactly but it sounds like that
that's what it [ __ ] sounds like to me
i'll show it to you you decide
i'm not the decision maker here i just
just put the [ __ ] on air
oh good morning to everyone christina is
here robin's here amanda's here forrest
is here from facebook andrea is here for
facebook lisa's here from facebook
nancy's here
midas lisa's here johnny from facebook
is here patty's here there are so many
new viewers
there are so many new viewers out there
i want to reiterate
how you will and go and watch the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday at
noon eastern 11 central live
live
live
streaming youtube twitter twitch go
subscribe to the youtube channel even if
you're gonna watch this thing
on a different platform go subscribe to
youtube that helps us out a lot
just type in tony michael's podcast at
the top of youtube or you can go to
thetonymichaels.com and find all the
links there
you can go to the minus touch facebook
page you can like me on facebook i have
a facebook page i have an instagram
go go follow all the things and
subscribes to all the things all the
thingy things out there
even even your favorite place to
download the podcast don't miss the
audio version of the podcast
on apple spotify google your favorite
directory make sure you leave us a five
star review while you're there
go over and give us some reviews you
know to
help out with the troll reviews and we
got some trolls that came over and gave
some reviews you know they don't like me
i guess they don't like the truth that i
tell and how i tell it
with gusto and the f word [ __ ] them i
don't care [ __ ] them
so welcome welcome to all the new
listeners we appreciate you you being
here and if you can't make it every
single day no problems no problems at
all if you miss part of the show it's
always on youtube it lives on facebook
it lives on the tweety tweets and it
lives over on twitch for a while
so go
check
out
go check out
the podcast and all your directories and
all the places we stream live it's a
live show live radio show here it's kind
of what we
model it after his radio he ain't seen
these right wing nut bag talk show host
well we figured the left wing needed one
so here i am
here i am for your enjoyment and your
pleasure
we're going to go through the tweety
tweets and journey turns today our
co-host gabe and executive producer gabe
sanchez is going to join us at the
bottom of the hour i believe
and then we're going to have a special
pop-in guest today uh rachel bitkoffer
is going to jump in
she's going to stop by some point during
the show
so we'll have rachel with us you guys
know rachel is a political strategist
and she loves to give her opinion and we
love how she gives it
she does not give a [ __ ] she's and not
one [ __ ] to give
besides pro-democracy that's that's what
rachel is concerned about and she
focuses a lot on messaging so maybe
we'll talk today about what the
messaging looks like coming out of
russia and ukraine i think that's huge
huge messaging you we're gonna watch a
video
of people protesting
that [ __ ] [ __ ] box over at fox news
tucker carlson
so maybe maybe uh there'll be some
movement on the messaging in this
country
just like there was movement on the the
don't say gay bill in florida
those [ __ ] scumbag republicans down
in florida and today we see tennessee
republicans boy
those tennessee republicans have to out
florida florida
i told you this was going to happen
i told you this is going to happen so
the biggest complaint the biggest
complaint
look you liberals you lib charge down in
florida we don't want people sexualizing
children we just want older men to be
able to marry them
legally you know
legally marry children
you know that sort of thing that has
nothing to do with sexualizing children
at all get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] so we're gonna we're gonna
take out the trash today and we're gonna
go through tennessee republicans we got
jd vance we got putin jason miller's on
the list
i love when i get the i i love when i
get to dunk jason miller in the trash
and then
because elon musk
uh just bought nine percent of twitter
uh trump is simping for him
oh it's it's hardcore trump is something
for him and you know you know donald
trump has already tried to get elon musk
on the [ __ ] phone no [ __ ] doubt in
my mind
that [ __ ] is probably stuck
texting him as we speak
i bet [ __ ] elon musk has had to block
that [ __ ] already
because true social
true socials in the goddamn landfill at
this point
so donald trump wants his twitter
account back
and so do all his simping maga trump
pumping idiots
you're like oh bring trump back please
to twitter i thought you hated twitter i
thought you don't like twitter
well now the elon's gonna own it
elon definitely
will bring back trump as if elon musk
with nine percent has the ability just
to wave his magic wand and bring trump
back
but you know trump's texting him you
know he's simping him man
kissing his [ __ ] ass
come on elon please
please let me back on the platform
oh good [ __ ] tuesday morning good
tuesday morning so we're gonna go
through the tweety tweets and attorney
trends today and there's a lot again
there's a lot of trash to be taken out
today
so why don't we just start taking out
the trash
right now let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show to the tony
michaels podcast where now we're to the
part where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends and take
out the [ __ ] trash
the garbage as it is
and with republicans in this country
with these fascist nazis holding these
rallies
and passing walls like sexualizing uh
gender and children's gender down in
florida that's what they're doing when
they pass a law down in florida they're
sexualizing children's gender down in
florida there's nothing sexual about
gender but these [ __ ] weirdos want to
sexualize gender all day long not only
do they want to sexualize gender they
want grown ass men to marry children
in tennessee i'm not [ __ ] you we're
gonna go to that part of the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
now i'm not making this [ __ ] up
oh you're
you liberals
you liberals with your obsessed with
chil we're not obsessed with children i
mean other than their education and
their health care
and their bellies being full like having
warm beds full bellies
being being highly educated
and having decent [ __ ] health care
that's what that's what
most of
us libtards want for children in this
country
that's it
you are the ones who are totally focused
on marrying younger children
to older men
sexualizing their gender you people are
[ __ ] weird
you people are [ __ ] weird you're
weird you [ __ ] weirdos
gqp weirdos
as they were as they were boy you guys
there's a lot of people from facebook on
here debbie's here anita's here hello
good morning to everyone crystal's here
kelly's here citizen jay is here i hope
i didn't miss anybody there's a lot of
people um watching live again you can go
to the youtube channel and we got super
chat now if you guys don't know what
super chat is it's the ability to help
the show out you can buy a super sticker
do a super chat so remember you can go
over to the youtube and do that right
there in the chat
and i'll try to bring you in on the show
uh tomorrow in this special announcement
why why before we get to the tweety
tweets in terms of tomorrow we're
supposed to have aaron parnez on
um aaron parnez is the is a co-host of
zoomed in podcast with mindus touch he's
also
also a lawyer and um he has ties to
ukraine he still has family in ukraine
he's going to give us a little bit of an
update we're going to go through a
little bit of ukraine today
and the horrors
and and bucha i think it's bucha i think
i was saying buca yesterday babucha i
think is how they say it the town's name
the atrocities that are happening there
and the propaganda the fox news style
propaganda that's being put out in
russia to try to convince the russian
people that vladimir putin is not
committing war crimes and president
biden is having none of that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
none of that [ __ ]
neither is the u.n council
now they need to charge
vladimir putin as soon as they possibly
can with war crimes
now
now
immediately
immediately
anita says i should check out facebook
stars i don't know what facebook stars
is i don't know much about facebook
i don't i used to a little bit but not
anymore not anymore not much
so you're going to inform me what stars
is
now you can go follow my facebook page
just type in the tony michaels and
you'll find it you'll find it
or you can go to thetonymichaels.com and
find it there thank you lisa for the
super chat
don't let jeannie thomas be yesterday's
news oh
jeannie thomas is on my radar don't
think we'll ever forget about the
important uh things to talk about these
traders make sure we throw these traders
in the trash lisa
absolutely
we will continue to throw these traders
in the trash and matter of fact there
was a little bit of news out of the
january 6 select committee and a little
bit of talky talk maybe we'll maybe
we'll get to that uh today in the
trinity trends and the tweety tweets as
we roll through the timeline let's go to
the timeline right now
let's make this a little bigger so yeah
folks out there can see it
okay let's zoom out here
come on there we go okay
here's the
here's the video from jd vance should we
do jd vance first should we go and just
dunk him in the [ __ ] trash right now
or should we wait i think i want to wait
i want to wait till the bottom of the
hour for jd vance i want gabe to get in
on the uh the fun
with jd vance we'll come back
to jd vance minus touch tweets
why are tennessee huh
gotta get the zoom right why are tennis
come on
it's not cooperating today
that's usually a monday thing but
today's tuesday but it's not cooperating
here we go let's try this one more time
why are tennessee republicans trying to
pass a merry little kids bill
that will allow them to marry children
of any age
merry little kids bill no [ __ ] it's a
thing
in tennessee they want to be able to
marry children these republicans they
are [ __ ] weird
um here's the article this is truly sick
keep your children away from the
republican party
they they're totally [ __ ] focused on
sexualizing children's gender they can't
help it
they they definitely they definitely
don't want children to be gay maybe
that's so they can [ __ ] marry him in
tennessee i don't know it's really
[ __ ] weird they need to stop focusing
on children's sexuality their gender
being sexual they need to stop focusing
on children's genitalia and they
definitely definitely need to lay off
the whole marrying children thing
get the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
how in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] are we
still
are we still debating well both parties
are the same
oh both parties are the same it's the
same thing doesn't matter if you like
democrats get the [ __ ] out of here it is
not the goddamn same it's not
when you have when you elect republicans
what they do
is they don't they don't focus on
children's education
they don't focus on making sure children
have enough to eat
or housing a warm bed to sleep they
don't focus on children's healthcare
they could give two [ __ ] shits if a
children if a child is hungry uneducated
or out in the cold they don't give a
[ __ ] i mean unless they're unless
they're you know a fetus in the womb
then they give a [ __ ]
but as long as long as you're outside
the womb they don't give two [ __ ]
two [ __ ] about that child's hunger
their education their health care or if
they got a warm place to sleep [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you can go [ __ ] yourself
if you're a child under the age of 18
from zero to 18
but
oh but man they really are obsessed
absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with their
gen gen sexualizing children's gender
their genitalia and bathrooms
and now they want to marry children
and both parties are the same get get
i'm sick of that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
like this katanji brown jackson
confirmation they're making it sound
like and the media is doing this [ __ ]
too oh both sides both sides wouldn't
elect both sides wouldn't elect contanji
brand then no one's gonna elect a a
supreme court justice anymore no one's
gonna confirm a supreme kick
shut the [ __ ] up we got mitt romney lisa
murkowski several republicans
that have already committed
to voting for judge brown jackson
because she is the most qualified judge
that has ever sat before the senate
judiciary committee for the nomination
of the supreme court justice
and it ain't because she's a black woman
it's because she's a black woman
she had to earn that seat and she did
she wasn't giving it to her for
privilege or because the federal society
paid for them to sit there for her to
sit there you dumb [ __ ] she earned that
[ __ ]
she earned that seat
and she earned it by being the most
qualified person to ever be nominated to
supreme court
seat
it's ridiculous absolutely ridiculous uh
amy lynn says tennessee republicans are
[ __ ] disgusting for putting forth a
bill that would let you married a child
might as well change the state model to
pedophiles welcome to tennis in
tennessee this is this is the craziest
part
about this whole gqp projection
because marjorie taylor green was also
trending for the word pedophile saying
that katanji brown jackson
is pro pedophile
what the [ __ ] are you marjorie taylor
green you love ron desantis yo
she's got it she's gotta love to marry a
child bill in tennessee
she's gotta love mary kids marrying kids
she's got to why cou i mean
how couldn't she she's [ __ ] fascist
she hasn't spoke out against it has she
where
show me the tweet where she has said
tennessee republicans are pro-pedophile
she hasn't
she called katanji brown jackson pro
pedophile for sentencing pedophiles to
federal prison
judge brown jackson
sentenced
pedophiles
and child molesters chomos
to federal prison
tennessee republicans want to make sure
they can legally marry children
the [ __ ] out of here
okay
um here's the other good liars video
that we want to go through um that i was
talking about where it's at the trump
rally and a trump supporter
talks about biden and putin
it is some scary ass [ __ ] and i'm gonna
break down why
this video
of the good liars asking this woman here
at the trump rally is [ __ ] terrifying
it's terrifying why it is even more
scary than a congresswoman standing on
stage
saying that that trump captured osama
bin laden and there was no war
during trump's presidency
i'm telling you this is some scary stuff
you don't you watch this video and you
think nah nah i mean it's you know what
is it what a you know no it's some scary
ass [ __ ] and i'm gonna break down why um
they're they're one again they're
wanting trump back on twitter i said
bring trump back on twitter it's hard to
tweet from a federal prison you don't
get a cell phone in federal prison like
there is no cell phone in federal prison
and i don't know if you've been paying
attention to some of the the court cases
here recently but donald trump is not in
a position to say that he's
he's going to skate on crimes that he's
committed a federal judge out in
california you remember
last week we forget these things
said in an open court ruled during the
eastman email for the eastman emails
for the eastman emails
what he did is ruled that donald trump
and and john eastman committed crimes
yep we also see that pomeranz the
special prosecutor
who assistant prosecutor in the
manhattan d.a who resigned also said in
his resignation letter
that the the indictment would come down
for the crimes that trump committed
all's brag has to do is bring him
forward
and i think we're going to see some
movement in that everyone's like oh it's
over and the man had da's office
he's not going to be held accountable
don't don't get your [ __ ]
undies in a bunch here
the governor new york controls
who the d.a is in a case
especially when the d.a isn't doing
their [ __ ] job the governor of the
state of missouri our state of
new york excuse me i'm in missouri
that's new york
i think about the governor here what a
[ __ ]
uh but the governor in the state most
states have control over prosecuting
attorneys
they're elected officials
mj is here she says whoopsie better late
welcome nj
if anyone doesn't know everyone give
fire to mj mj has been in these live
chats
from the very beginning before we even
started streaming on the podcast it was
just some crazy thing we did over on
twitch she's been here thank you mj for
joining us every single day
and she says hey to the [ __ ] fam and
midas mighty
saw you all with the mooch last night
mooch
yeah
um uh
the uh mooch was on midas touch podcast
last night i gotta go check that out i i
was busy last night
had some soccer practice and some things
so i wasn't able to catch the show live
so i'm gonna have to go back and rewatch
the mooch on them
on the midas touch podcast of course we
had the mooch on uh was it several weeks
ago we had the mooch on anthony
scaramucci now that that interview is on
youtube
that's why you gotta subscribe to the
youtube channel so you don't miss any of
that stuff you can go over there and
look at all the interviews we got brad
bad br brad
bad brad berkwit
anthony scaramucci we got missy modell
um
tasha adams
dakota adams the uh estranged wife and
son of stuart rhodes uh let's see what
else we got a ton of popock
uh michael popock from legal af and
rachel bitkoffer the political
strategist over there
there's all kinds of interviews over
there go check out the youtube channel
check out some of those clips go to the
clip go to the clip playlist okay let's
see what else do we get going here
oh yes oh yes this is a great one eric
swalwall
says
m-i-c-k-e-y because lauren bobert and
bone-headed [ __ ] she says next year the
woke disney
lobbyist will ask congress to extend
mickey mouse's trademark i think not of
course she spelled mickey
m-i-c-k-y
there's a there's a and
eric swallow points that there's
literally a song that taught millions of
us how to spell it
if these losers aren't weren't dumb
we'd be screwed
m-i-c-k-e-y-m-o-u-s-e
you remember the song
it's not difficult
literally
it taught us how to spell it
whoosh
i mean you know is it surprising that
lauren bobert doesn't know how to spell
mickey mouse i mean is it really
somebody sounds surprising
it really isn't
what's surprising is is that when she
typed in mickey mouse on her phone and
i'm not sure i haven't checked this but
i would imagine if you type in mickey
mouse on your phone and spell checks it
so even her [ __ ] phone is stupid
it's not just her
her [ __ ] phone is stupid her phone
couldn't even [ __ ]
autocorrect this whoosh thanks
thank you eric swalwell for your tweet
oh here's the here's the mooch link
jordy's got it here
um and mooch never holds back so go
check that out here we'll we'll give
jordy some love here thanks for your
tweet jordy everybody go check out the
mooch
on the midas touch podcast last night go
rewatch that
and you can watch it on the minus touch
facebook page but don't go over there
yet stay live with us and then go watch
the uh
then go watch the mooch then go watch
the moon um someone said don't don't
take genie thomas out of the news well
here you go hoodlum um says just in
clarence and jeannie thomas adopt the q
anon
man don't know if it dops him like as a
son
or as like a pet
you know i mean i mean you know he's got
like the the get up you know
i don't know
i don't know do you think do you think
the costume shop
and he bought his costume at really is
culpable
in the uh
january 6 insurrection
or at least at least his at least his
conviction and his plea deal that he
made with the feds the costume shop has
to have some kind of culpability right
thank you a non-shaman ah thank you
hoodlum for your for your tweet
featured on today's [ __ ] list roundup
oh uh minus stacy thank you very much
for uh bringing this up um to attention
she says omg two democracy fighters
together on one podcast april 10th
april 10th i'm going to be on bad brad
berkowitz
show the bad brad berkwitch show
um
stacy
says she has the mine tony michaels
podcast
on in the background
when she's many afternoons topics
covered with an honest take on where we
are and what we can do
and brad
bad brad berkwit
all i can say is awesome moving humanity
forward so thanks brad for having me on
your show on april 10th check that out
check that out on april 10th i'll be on
um bad brad berkowitz show
okay
oh here is here's here's a marge mercury
mercury taylor green one of her
you know we have lauren beaubert
marjorie taylor green
um all these uh
sarah palin's out sarah palin and sarah
palin you know what i mean like you know
it used to be like we were like oh sarah
palin i can't get any dumber than that
nope
sure can't
sure can't get any better than that come
on
it's dumb
dumber and [ __ ] dumber in a
box of rocks not even squirrel turds and
sarah palin she's running for a
congressional seat in alaska
which doesn't make her the dumbest
congressional candidate now i mean she's
still i mean she's striving you know
she's really working hard to be a better
sarah palin than marjorie taylor greene
and lauren bobert
but lauren bobert and marjory taylor
green about sarah palin sarah palin at
this point listen to this [ __ ]
question what is a woman
because she said she's not a biologist
okay okay so she's talking about the
judge brown jackson here
and
it's not just judge brown jackson has
been asked this [ __ ] question
in the last several weeks
i've watched several people get asked
this question
what is a woman
all right
now let me let me tell you what you were
supposed to say to this question because
a lot i've watched a lot of liberals
they're like uh but i'm not a
and katangi brown jackson did a decent
job but she said i'm not a biologist
[ __ ] that [ __ ] here's what you say
here's what you say when some dumbass
asks you what a woman is you say it's
it's a gender that a person identifies
as
it's a it's a purse it's a gender that a
person identifies as
like some some women are
are you know
women some women are trans women but
it's a gender that people identify as
it's not [ __ ] complicated
and if you want to really go after you
say well what are you what what are you
do you identify as a man or a woman or
whatever they're well yeah okay so
you're your gender is a woman is that
what you identify
yeah it really is not complicated but
listen to what this [ __ ] [ __ ] box says
about women in general i'm gonna tell
you right now what does that woman
say
i'm gonna tell you we're a creation of
god yeah we came from adam's river right
that's that's crazy that's that's what
that book says that's what the book says
we are we may be the weaker sex we are
the weaker sex but we are our partner
our husband's wife
the weaker six let's bring let's bring
our co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez and and see if he thinks women
are the weaker sex do you think women
are the weaker sexier gabe i mean do you
think no no no i actually i actually
think the ex at the opposite that
that that if we if we actually put you
know dudes
you know stop this power trip and [ __ ]
and step aside and let women you know
come in and run the country and do the
government thing right
like dudes and guys would be so much
better off we'd be so much better off
you'd have higher wages you'd have
better health care you'd have a hell of
a lot better education you'd probably
have a better retirement system you
would probably retire earlier live
happier if you would just
let the
the better of the sexes do the job that
needs to be done in this country
no no for sure i i think
uh dudes in general yeah uh really i
know i know a lot of dudes do you know a
lot of dudes i know a lot of dudes and
uh you know nine times out of ten we
[ __ ] the bed right okay it's horrible we
do a terrible job we think we're doing a
great thing
we
oh we love the parent we love the pound
our chest about overly confident
and um our ego gets ahead of us
uh and i would say that most of the time
women have to come in and clean that
[ __ ] up you know right and and to their
just for most of the like right like
yeah right yeah they're like oh you guys
made a mess again god damn i gotta clean
things up and make it better
and uh incredibly grateful for the you
know the women in my life who who helped
me be a better person
um but i very much disagree with
whatever [ __ ] margaret taylor green
is on i just want to put this out there
okay marger taylor green says
um you know
uh we're we come from adam's rib
uh
that's just false
uh you know we all if that was the case
you know how much incest we have all
come from then if those are the two
first people it's like they just [ __ ]
themselves and then make a baby they
[ __ ] each other and then those babies
[ __ ] each other and those babies
babies [ __ ] each other i mean we'd all
be dead now wait a second you're gonna
get you're gonna get the gqp all excited
because they love sexualizing children's
gender and they love when you talk about
marrying children right i mean they
[ __ ] love it especially when it's
children of of your family because in
tennessee they're not only passing bills
for children to marry for for grown men
to marry children which is really
[ __ ] weird right but they're also
which is
not just a reversion but they're taking
they're taking the rights away from
children like literally they're taking
the right the autonomy away from a child
now
um
and and they're they're they're being
statutory rapists but here's here's
here's the craziest part about
tennessee there's also
a a bill that is similar to the one in
texas it's a bounty hunter bill
where a family member can sue
their family for being raped by their
family and then having an abortion it's
really [ __ ] weird and they say it
like right out in the open they're like
yeah well you know the person who rapes
them can't sue them but right and that's
not only that it's it's also there's an
unlimited amount of people who could
come forward so like it could be
the father
and the son
and the holy spirit you know they could
all come over and sue the woman
right so it's like an unlimited amount
of lawsuits that could come against this
woman basically you know bankrupting her
uh because she was the victim of said
rape or ancestor whatever
uh because obviously the man and his
family are the real victims here right
exactly that's the real problem but
marcie taylor green you know she comes
out there and she's like oh you know we
come for the rib we are the weaker sex
we are husband's wife
i find that funny considering the fact
that this woman had two affairs one with
a polyamorous tantric sex guru and the
manager of the crossfit gym that she
worked at
so right wow for someone to come over
again you know it's just classic you
know hypocritical christians coming over
with their gqp fascism trying to tell
you what you should and shouldn't do and
that's only for you rules don't apply to
them
yeah of course
i can't find the tweet exactly right now
but there's a tweet out there i think it
was yesterday right
when it wasn't it wasn't it yesterday
that um she tweeted something about
katanji brown she said tweeted um oh she
was in romney she said something said
romney murkowski and uh
someone else were all pro-pedophile
which i'm like isn't that
isn't that definition you know what's
what's funny is that um
what she's saying about she was holding
hands with matt gates okay that guy's on
a [ __ ] fbi
trafficking so she should not be able to
come after anyone for anything related
to uh children or anything sexual nature
okay that woman is weird she and lauren
beauberg have some sexual just just sort
of interest and uh and fantasy or fetish
around guns okay
guns i don't know where they use the
guns you know maybe they use them on the
range maybe they use them at home i'm
not really sure but what i can say is
those two
idiots
uh have this weird fetish around guns
okay
well they have a lot of weird fetishes
around a lot of things here's the tweet
right she tweeted murkowski collins and
romney are pro pedophile which she's
talking about because they he she said
they just voted for kbj right which is
judge brown jackson right for supreme
court because she's the most qualified
person that's ever sat in the seat to be
nominated in the senate judiciary
committee or in the senate in general
right to be nominated for a supreme
court justice seat
in our modern history possibly ever
and she calls him pro-pedophile
all the while i'm sure
i'm sure this bonehead supports the
tennessee bill
oh 100 the marry a child bill in
tennessee
she probably no she's gqp she's america
first she's america first baby hey so
she the children right from the gqp
please save the children from no [ __ ] i
mean it's it's really it's getting
really gross speaking of america first
did you see
did you see the jd even knew jd vance
head did you see this no i have not oh
my god this [ __ ] guy look at this
[ __ ] so jd vance ron posted the campaign
uh let me let me read this here he says
in a campaign marked by one shameless
act after another desperately seeking
traction jd vince for jd bands [ __ ] that
guy releases an ad
ron didn't write that i'm ad libbing
here yeah yeah writes an ad that starts
with are you racist do you hate mexicans
i'm not [ __ ] you those are the
quotes and the end
and ends with blaming border the border
for his mother's long-term addiction now
what i'm going to show you this ad and
then i'm going to show you a different
version of it that okay that i found
possibly oh okay um
i i don't you know
we'll watch both
are you a racist no do you hate mexicans
the media calls us racist for wanting to
build trump's wall
they censor us but it doesn't change the
truth joe biden's open border is killing
ohioans with more illegal drugs and more
democrat voters pouring into this
country
more democrat voters
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you know you
just you did an interview with bad brad
berkwith and you guys talked and you
guys should go to youtube you can go to
our channel it's down on the playlist or
you can go to brad's channel but you
guys talked about how
in this country right now the hispanic
and latino community there's a lot of
them which which in in a lot of respects
they're they have a very high faith a
lot of them are in the cavalry religion
so a lot of them are conservative like
the actual you know right the actual
conservatives right actual conservative
so a lot of them have a lot of political
conservative views and he's calling he's
co he's basically saying that latino and
hispanics
are democrat voters like it's automatic
right he's also assuming that ohio is a
high traffic area for
the for mexicans coming across the
border that's just not true that is well
i mean chicago is it ohio down on the
mexican i mean i'm i'm it's right next
door right right but here's the thing
mexicans oh my god mexicans
uh uh will walk around
ohio to avoid it oh okay that's on their
way to chicago yeah yeah well i know my
when my family crossed the border they
saw ohio and they're like nah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] that [ __ ] they got
like it took them an extra three weeks
they walked around that [ __ ] right well
you know what's crazy is this
[ __ ] right here is famous for
abandoning rue america for elite america
like that's what he's famous for it's
like oh you shouldn't be rule because
you're bumpkins right like you sh and
and he was anti-trump now he's not even
pro-trump he's making sure that he's
getting the right audience he's like are
you racist or are you hate mexicans then
you're going to want to watch this ad
right you're going to want to watch is
it here's the thing
some people
i i feel like the questions are like
this like he asked the questions like
are you racist do you hate mexicans and
one group goes hell yeah you know
and then they watch it he's like the
border yeah man yeah [ __ ] the air the
border right then you got the other
group who's like are you racist no do
you hate mexicans no right like it's
just i i feel like
that that [ __ ] type of question
uh because there's no right answer
unless you of course you're just like
yeah i am a racist and i do hate
mexicans right that if they were saying
that
uh but i feel like that's the type of
question where it's like you answer yes
or no and you still can get to the same
conclusion of like getting to this like
well people think because we chose a
safe border and it's like
yeah i want a safe border because i'm a
racist or yeah i want to say border but
yeah i'm not a racist but right no but i
mean it doesn't oh it's it's a it's a
dumb i mean
it's so dumb anyway well that's what
i'll say
let's let's finish it because he really
does dismount uh incredible here this
issue is personal
i nearly lost my mother to the poison
coming across our border
no child should grow up an orphan i'm jd
vance and i approve this message because
whatever they call us
we will put america first okay
go ahead go ahead okay
his mother obviously died from a drug
overdose or some sort of addiction right
uh but how do we know
right okay but also how do we not know
this is with an addiction from opioids
right doesn't ohio have a huge
population of opioid
well i i mean opioids are a problem in
our country right but like for sure i
gotta i gotta look you gotta look this
up well here here's what i said about
the um
the the uh the video i said i said are
you racist do you hate mexis mexicans
then vote for me jd vance i mean like
literally
because i think you're saying you're
saying what i'm saying here you're like
it could be taken both ways right but he
really wants people to take it as are
you racist do you hate mexicans then
vote for me jd vance because i will do
that you know whatever it is that you
need me to do rather it's uh you know do
the simping that you do for for for
republicans hating to be called racist
even though we are or if you are a
full-on racist and admit it and you
actually hate mexicans then i'm for you
too okay see this whole thing that he's
presented is [ __ ] because here's the
thing i'm i'm reading an article about
his book and about his bio and it says
uh
uh bev vance's behavior you know taking
into the world jd's mother was arrested
during domestic abuse squabble with uh
mama that once again spiraled out of
control she also started abusing
prescription drugs to which she had easy
access as a nurse wait a second wait a
second there is you're telling me
there's a border at the hospital where
she worked
and she was she was a nurse for the
mexican cartel
apparently big pharma brings brings
prescription drugs right across the
board around this time stealing from her
patients to feed her addiction
ultimately she was fired for
rollerblading through the emergency room
okay evidently her substance abuse had
altered her mental state to the point
where she seemed like a normal like that
seemed like the normal and appropriate
thing okay uh yeah it says she revealed
to him that she had turned to drugs to
escape her financial distress or
financial stress and to cope with the
loss of her father
um
so when jd vance
is trying to see what he's doing here is
he doesn't specifically say
that
it's the addiction is because of the
southern border but he's implying it
right well but here's the thing it's
like
in jd vance's mother's situation right
she totally
totally
i i she has drug addiction and you could
say that uh jd vance should be making
ads about mental health care in this
country and health care in general to
give people health care so it could help
people like his mom who had an addiction
who who couldn't who couldn't even do
her job and keep her job because she had
such an addiction
there is there is plenty of room for
policy to make sure people like jd
vance's mom
it doesn't happen or we try to reverse
the course of some of that addiction
nope he doesn't say that he didn't say
he's like yeah blaming all the mexicans
like he literally says it in the
beginning right because he's like we're
building a wall to secure our country
from drugs those drugs that killed my
mother actually the people you really
want to talk to is big pharma those were
the ones with the drugs prescription
drugs the ones that your mother as a
nurse stole from her patients so don't
come into this [ __ ] saying that it's
mexicans or the southern border like i
agree
because it's right exactly
right it was
right these drugs mrs vance right you
know like well you know what it's the
same thing with gas prices when when the
the entire country should be blaming uh
big oil right for gouging us because
crude is dropping and gasoline is not
dropping at the same rate they're
gouging the [ __ ] out of us and until the
american people actually pluck their
head out of their asses and start
blaming uh big oil then big oil is going
to keep gouging you as long as because
you know big oils spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars every week to pull
the american people of who they're
blaming for for gas prices and as long
as they keep blaming biden the old
companies can be like well we're going
to keep these [ __ ] prices up what do
we care about blame and biden right and
tell the american people that come to
their [ __ ] census and realize who is
at fault for the high gas prices at the
pump
they're not going to change it the same
way the same way jd vance is blaming
mexicans the border and biden on on like
you're saying the big pharma's problem
it's big pharma's problem and until we
start blaming it on the right people
you're not going to change it here is
here is another version of this ad
i just want to play this um i found it
somewhere
uh maybe on my computer i'm not sure
exactly where event let me let's look
are you a racist
do you hate mexicans
i'm jd vance and i approve this message
that's it that's it
really i mean i i i don't think we chan
it didn't change any words that was a
clean cut i don't know it looked like it
was perfect
that looks like the ad and really
honestly this is a seven second ad jd
vance i mean talk about being effective
right jd vance if you're out there
really honestly this is going to be a
cheaper way for you to get on the
airwaves you're literally only gonna
have to buy seven seconds you're not
gonna have to buy the whole 30. right
you can run this thing three different
times yeah three ads boom boom boom i'm
just trying to help you out buddy here's
here it is again
are you a racist
do you hate mexicans
i'm jd vance and i approve this message
i mean yeah i can watch that several
times by the by the seventh time i would
say hey
jd vance
is a racist i really tried to look for
um vote for me but he didn't he didn't
say quite that in the end so i just
i but i i didn't doctor it at all i just
got those
those are his words he said his words
those are his words um so the other
video i want to show you gabe is another
video
um at the trump rally let's see if i can
find it here um last yesterday we
watched did you see the one about the
the space force space cadet lady i did
oh my gosh she was off a rocker this
one's insane too you said uh what here
yeah um this is good liars um this is
some scary [ __ ] like the whole space
force they're going to have military
tribunals like that's every day they
have some new conspiracy like that does
the other it's some kind of delusional
fairy tale [ __ ] that they made up on i
can't believe i can't even write this
[ __ ] okay right i know i know well i
mean it's hard to even [ __ ] do parody
and comedy anymore because here's the
thing here's the thing this is what goes
on my mind sometimes i go oh yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] bizarre i'm gonna write
that right and i go no
yes just feels it feels right it feels
like them yeah well yeah but i'm also
just like oh that feels weight like
that's not grounded that's there's no
way they're like out in the atmosphere
somewhere with the [ __ ] space lasers
and space force right like that's what
that's how far i feel when i'm writing
this and i go
they would say this and i go oh my god
it doesn't it doesn't feel real
right for what they're saying and then
they make a video and they say it and
i'm like
but have you ever come across this space
space for [ __ ] till tell this no not
until that woman who was like
she was like walk with me
even even walter because i think walter
repost that's where i've seen it walter
masterson who's been it god knows how
many dozens of trump rallies he was at
january 6th the insurrection and even he
was like i've never heard this this is
he's like i heard a lot of crazy
conspiracies and this one this one might
be the one now now we watched walter i
believe it was the last one in um
in arizona he asked some people about
putin and ukraine right but this
this woman the way she answers this
question
is [ __ ] weird it's scary and i think
it's dangerous there's 2.4 million views
on twitter on this with the good liars
but i want you guys to watch we can't
look away from these these crazy
wackadoos um because this person
probably votes but let's watch what
she's the question that he asked is
would you rather
have a president biden or vladimir putin
this is a would you rather question
would you rather
have a president joe biden or vladimir
putin let's listen who would you rather
have president joe biden or vladimir
putin oh putin
i mean not even
oh
oh putin like yeah there's like instant
uh putin like didn't really have to
think about it didn't really have to
consider the option it's not like there
were any options really there it was hey
who do you support the guy who just
committed genocide and is killing a
bunch of ukrainians and sending russians
into ukraine whether they know what
they're doing or not
and uh you know not that guy right like
do you want a killer or a non-killer
you know i think the most dangerous part
about this
is that these people
are willing
i i really believe this woman would mark
her name nick or her mark next to putin
if it wasn't about and and that is the
most dangerous thing that i think that
these people have wound themselves and
painted themselves into this corner so
much right that they actually have to
stand and be
they an ally with a murderous i just
feel like there's the
the ability to get out of this way of
thinking and this reality that people
have set themselves in is so
far gone in my mind where we are
believing
i mean well here she'll talk and she'll
say some things that are just [ __ ]
insane mm-hmm
here let me let me play definitely
and and what and why is that um i
believe he's been given a tough uh oh my
god since since world war ii uh russia's
been the bad guy
when in actuality the nazis left germany
what
and they ended up going to the ukraine
coming in here george bush was actually
what the [ __ ]
george bush was actually a nazi now i
know
i'm not i'm not a george w bush fan
right yeah i don't think is she talking
about george h or or w i i don't know i
it's hard to tell maybe she's talking
about both of them it could be i mean
and that's why she's saying george but
she may not know the difference right
right i mean really honestly she may not
know the difference i don't understand
how she came to that conclusion
well
i i mean i know how all of our we got a
lot of new listeners out there on
facebook right yeah there's a lot of new
listeners out there on facebook and we
love having the facebook listeners here
but the people on facebook who are
listening to us right now on facebook
understand the actual swamp the q anon
swamp um the isis
is this the same is the same one where
the the drug field orgies happen at this
is this is it that's the swamp yeah okay
so they're like ivermectin fueled yeah
well i mean you know it there's like a
buffet of of what you could right
there's a medley of drugs right right
yeah yeah yeah you know i mean
ivermectin is just one of them i don't
know if they crush it up and snort but
yeah they're like come [ __ ] at big
pharma you know right right yeah well i
mean yeah they love big
[Music]
there's this big conspiracy that big
pharma is trying to you know manipulate
you with the vaccine but ivermectin and
the others
that's okay they're not there's no
consensus
baby you know [ __ ] big pharma oh my
god this
she's on some [ __ ] drugs apparently
because it's insane the whole that whole
she says basically that that putin's
getting the raw deal here yeah yeah poon
you know what he doesn't seem like such
a bad guy right he's got what she said
she's like would i vote for him hell
yeah i'd vote for him he seems like a
real you know real you know here we go
this is where we heard it before he
seems like a real down earth guy he just
says it like it is he talks how he feels
and he tells you what he thinks right
right like even even even if other i've
heard that before the truth even if
other people don't think of this truth
right speaking of [ __ ] bags that don't
tell the truth did you hear
did you hear that trump is simping elon
musk
oh is he begging for his oh my god i bet
he's
i i i don't know if you have like an
insight to mar-a-lago and if there's
going to be a statement released or not
on
does he really sit back on twitter i
don't know i don't know i don't know i'm
just saying if you have the inside on
i've seen a bunch of other people within
the republican party be like all right
elon next next stop bring trump back
right it's like wait why don't you guys
go use the [ __ ] social network he
made right well because it's in the
landfill it's in the landfill come on
man that's the other day
they're like hey bring trump brac we're
staying on twitter
he just made a [ __ ] app for you all
and you didn't even show up to the house
party
i don't know
i
also the numbers the numbers when i've
done the digging into the app
they do not make sense
well you're talking about true social
yeah
yeah okay so intrude social they're uh
they are claiming like 800 000 people
follow trump you know 400
or whatever 100 i forget what the number
is follows don jr like there's all these
people however
when i look at the app and i see the app
signups that were up until like the
beginning of march
right there wasn't much after that
uh because you know uh devin nunes said
they were going to fix the air sign ups
that were happening
you mean the guy who gave up his
congressional seat to be the fall guy
for this exactly okay okay yeah yeah
whatever laundry griffin whatever
whatever federal crimes may come out of
through social he's gonna
so
in in the app you can well there's
analytics that you can follow outside
the app and though they show like you
know big sign ups the first few days and
the numbers just trail churchill as the
app falls down in the app store it gets
less size less downloads and you know
now it's not even in the top 200 in the
app store so you would have to
specifically like exclusively search for
it
to find it
now in that time sign ups have gone down
and these numbers that they're claiming
are following these accounts
don't add up because you because there's
not enough people on board the sign ups
don't equal the follower count so so i'm
because you tried to sign up right and
they put you on the wait i'm still i'm
still a wait list
300 059
whoa you're 300 000 in a line
yeah like three yeah three five nine
zero one one i think is my number so
you're in the top one million at least
oh yeah dude i'm yeah
i'm [ __ ] top [ __ ] but here's the
thing
don't you think that number's probably
inflated too they're like oh yeah
there's 300 000 here's the thing a lot
of people are like oh no man they got
this q system set up like the q system
was was built beforehand
they anticipated either the [ __ ] was
going to go sideways what do you mean by
that q system was built beforehand
because i'm not a tech guy so what do
you mean by that specifically so there's
a way that there's different tactics you
can use when people are signing up and
like if you're launching an app if you
want to launch an app and you want to
you want to build up the hype and say
like oh it's exclusive not everyone can
get in you're on the wait list oh my god
i can't believe i'm i'm this right it's
all marketing it's all right however
when you have a [ __ ] ton of errors for
signing up and you can't get into the
app and you you know you can't enter
email you can't enter your birthday you
can't enter this information actually
create a profile
once you finally do you get put on this
wait list right you're behind the velvet
rope before you get into the club
however no one's in the club and they're
just building hype by keeping everyone
outside now there's really the club's
like a piece of cardboard right right
it's like it would like some lights
behind it like an old cassette
right it's like one of those uh
hollywood sets where you just see the
the front right like it's just a wooden
panel with painted like a house on it
and you were to push it over
you would see that no one was inside
not even trump's inside you look at
different kevin nunes is just standing
at the door right he's just there in a
yeah exactly he's in a couch a cow
costume and he's like hey welcome guys
you know welcome to true social and
everyone's like you know he's like god
is like [ __ ] spinning
you know he's just maybe he's just doing
that right he's got a flashlight right
and he's yeah uh but the thing is they
built this they they built this like
wait list and you know no one can get in
and the people that are getting in are
noticing two things one there's only a
handful of high profile people who are
actually active and two there's a [ __ ]
ton of bots who have created a [ __ ] ton
of these random
just random so what you're saying is as
you're standing in line around the block
from the cardboard cutout that is too
social you're standing in line with a
bunch of cardboard cutouts like that
yeah yeah yeah you're saying you're like
a bunch of you're getting real people in
this line right or
you're seeing a bunch of like you know
impersonators like go into the club like
oh man do you see the kardashians one of
the club where you see this bird like no
nobody entered the club they were
already there to begin with they were
bots or they came in after and did the
sign of flow because there was you think
they create accounts for famous people
on there for them just i'm sure they
reserve the real estate just like on
getter ghetto released all the usernames
and i'm gonna safely assume that they
did the same thing for truth social so
what do you what do you mean they
reserved him so you mean like like let's
say just as an example of kim kardashian
she didn't actually open the getter
account they just reserved that handle
for so they released it like oh it's a
handle that's on here right right right
in the database they have all the user
records and they use the records that
are associated with real people and
prospective people and they say no one
can take that handle because that's
reserved for kim kardashian or that's
deserved for this person or that person
whatever right is that why devin nunes
worked so hard to make sure there was
not a word nunes and cow in a because i
hear i hear that's one reason why it
flopped is because he spent all his time
trying to figure out how he could make
sure no username could have the words
nunes or cow in it is that interesting
uh i wouldn't i wouldn't doubt it you
know if if they were like because
typically when you're like oh i want to
make an account you'll have uh
or like when it when a username is
randomly generated you want to avoid
certain syllables next to each other's
or vowel or sorry uh certain vowels next
to each other because they might create
certain words right right like
accidental swear words oh okay uh and so
this might be one of those things where
he's like i specifically don't want
anyone to say cow nunes nunes cow cow
nunes
they're like what things do you want to
suppress so no one can do it right right
right they're like they're like what
speech do you want to suppress right on
true social exactly they're like this is
what we can do and there's like here's a
long list there's like these are like
200 usernames and they're all with
newness in the name exactly right
like he just went on to twitter and
found every nickname people were saying
about devin nunes and then said okay
these are all the ones that are a no-go
right and all these usernames cannot
exist speaking of people who are
probably not and probably
uh reserved for a handle on uh true
social uh it just then ivanka trump is
testifying virtually uh to the january
sixth uh committee this morning for
sources familiar with the company are
they all have they all done it so far or
no i i'm not sure well the news is right
now
from hugo here that
ivanka trump is testifying um
virtually uh she didn't actually go to
washington
um i guess you know it's scary do a [ __ ]
show or something
via zoom
yeah so she did it i mean that's
virtually is what yeah what he's
reporting here same same way that uh
maybe she's doing it through true social
like maybe you know i don't know they're
using like a rumble video or something
yeah something like that here's the
thing
didn't uh
didn't uh
wow the boy the brahms doll what's his
face her husband jared kushner jared
kushner yeah last week yeah the
porcelain doll yeah yeah he did it last
week but he was in there for like six
hours well he definitely did it from the
toy box he did did he oh yeah
yeah he went he did it yeah he did it
from toy box he like had a little little
frame up right and they're like they're
like why did you come in here with a
plastic bin around your face do you
think his mouth nude any no not at all
[Music]
his mouth his mouth didn't move probably
yeah i would not imagine
i don't know uh so we got we
there's uh let's see what else did i
want to uh run by
the famous gabe sanchez here um for uh
his commentary it was the uh oh
we gotta get back to this the elon musk
buying oh 9.2 yeah
let's get back to this because i am we
you weren't on yesterday you were you
know yes i was i was but but elon musk
has bought 9.2 percent of twitter
now i i actually am not scared of this
right i i i mean that's why there's a
board right right exactly now he
basically bought his seat on the board
is what he's done here yeah yeah i mean
he didn't actually i mean he bought
twitter but he bought his seat on the
board yeah some people were like he
bought twitter he did not buy twitter he
just has the largest single shareholder
amount
at twitter which actually is the thing
that we shouldn't we should tax him into
oblivion so he can't afford the largest
chair of twitter right you know whatever
that's just but also yeah he's not he's
not going to have i mean like he might
have influence when it comes to like
uh
some well here's the thing i don't think
he'll have much influence outside of he
has the stake and the company because
again these are decisions the board has
to approve bigger decisions right if
there's product innovation that's not so
much a board style receipt or a decision
as it is
uh hey we're giving you an update in
this quarter and this is what we did or
this is what we plan to do and the board
says that's a good idea or maybe hold
off on that or you know so on and so
forth
but here's the thing though is here's
the thing though is that
don't
elon musk i i got this comment yesterday
because i i drugged him a little bit
yesterday because this news came out
yesterday but now it's still trending
because they want to bring they think
he's gonna bring back trump or some
stupid [ __ ] right um but i said
yesterday you know i kind of drug him a
little bit which i i actually you know
i'm with you i don't think this is that
significant other than the significant
part is that someone can actually afford
to buy nine percent of twitter and be
the largest and buy their [ __ ] board
seat but here's the thing
can you see trump like he's probably
right now like he can't stop texting he
can't stop texting elon musk he's
probably called him at least a hundred
times since since this news dropped
yesterday
can you imagine the phone calls that you
would get
i think he probably doesn't even know
elon's name he's like call
please call mr tesla call mr tech
alan tesla
sp let's speak to elon tesla or she's
like call up mr tesla and they're like
who is mr tesla and he's like you know
it's best friends with mr apple and he's
like right
all right right right tim apple tim
apple well you know
yesterday i drug and someone commented
down in the comments on youtube and you
guys can go look at it they're like oh
poor elon don't make fun of me i'm like
poor he invented the electric car i'm
like number one elon musk could not
invent the electric car right holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah what what
it it it never ends the stupidity never
ends in this country like elon musk did
not invent the electric car he just had
enough money from his little paypal
transaction
to open a company and by the way he
borrowed our money and we paid him the
taxpayers to make electric cars yeah
he's taking so much money and he didn't
pay taxes he's taking our money to make
those electric cars so
and then he complained this year yeah
about how he was going to pay or like
this past year is we pay the highest
amount of taxes and it's like
well yeah you took out a lot of money
yeah i mean also yeah you should be
taxed more but the fact that you were
taxed that much or that you had to pay
that much is because you took out so
much money because
you were going to solve world hunger
right that was a poll you did right so
you know yes the fact that some that
this goes to show you
that billionaires
can't spend their money fast enough like
right mckenzie uh
uh um
the the the previous wife ex-wife of of
jeff bezos right yeah she
uh was like in 2021 she she she sold
stock from amazon and then took you know
i forget the amount of billions that
were there and donated it to different
organizations by the end of the week she
had earned that money back in the market
so when somebody goes oh billionaires
this that it's like no you could still
do good and you still and you wouldn't
you would just net out you would just
get back to where you were poor elon
musk oh
poor poor him he just doesn't have
enough and we should stop making fun of
him listen because they also their point
was oh well he's providing internet to
ukraine he should provide internet to
everyone in this country yeah yeah and
probably everyone around the world don't
tell me that his move to provide
internet and ukraine doesn't have an
ulterior motive well it's evil musk well
you'll remember the whole what was it
last week he was like i'm challenging
putin to a
death match or some stupid [ __ ]
i don't know which i'm like this is the
way that i show posting a death match or
something this is the way that i look at
that i was like i couldn't quite get
into tweet but the way the way that i
feel about that situation was
look
uh it's a win-win situation okay because
either way
you're talking about the death match
right right right yeah i was like it's a
win-win because either way right we have
one less [ __ ]
okay one last rich [ __ ] right right
one that's a lot of money [ __ ] now i
don't know who the winner would be
obviously i feel like it would probably
be putin but who knows what do you mean
by how much wealth they have or who
would actually win the death i think who
would actually win the death match elon
musk i don't think is quite the most
trained meanwhile you got [ __ ] mr kgb
over here who like knows everything in
terms of like where to hit where to
punch where to shoot whatever vladimir
putin is is is is deadly in that way or
just just as a dictator he's just like
as a dictator his thing it would also be
like one of those things oh great let's
go into russia and we'll go hand-to-hand
comment you're winning and then he'd be
like
guard and then the guard would just you
know just say
why i mean would they do it bare-chested
because you know yeah yeah definitely
bare-chested right right he would have a
cigar elon would have a blunt you know
okay go rogan would be like ding ding
right and then
exactly yeah well i mean maybe
what was the uh claymation
um celebrity deathmatch it was that what
it was called yeah oh my god someone
needs to bring back celebrity death i
thought i think that show did someone do
the putin
putin elon musk
video i don't know did they do that i'm
just saying but i i feel like they
brought it back they're still producing
the show out there that might be a good
celebrity death match to show yeah and i
mean i'm with you i don't think it is a
bad idea for elon musk or vladimir putin
and to even throw deadly weapons like i
don't know like heavy mining equipment
or shovels
you know
anything like could cause blunt force
trauma i think we should throw that in
the ring with them if they're gonna have
this death match and i think we should
have it like in a cage and we should
lock that [ __ ] yeah yeah welcome
to the thunderdome baby
right only one can survive right
you know if they're going to do it do it
right do it right i mean who knows best
case scenario they both take each other
out
well you know that's all i'm you know
i'm not saying i'm not you know
promoting no no not at all i'm just
saying like if we look at the the
situation right one well i mean it's
elon musk's idea it's not our idea right
exactly
at the end of the day it's either gonna
be one or both of them will have removed
themselves from the situation great one
less dictator right one less another
just like regular rich [ __ ] you know
it
it seems great speaking of a murderous
dictator um
did you did you see some of the images
from uh bucha i think is how you
pronounce it i was saying
yeah i i saw yeah this weekend um it's
uh [ __ ] awful what has happened in
ukraine and what that murderous butcher
that piece of [ __ ] vladimir putin which
um it seems like uh
you know
joe biden is really uh
going to try to push for war crimes here
and it seems like you and his too um
there's a little bit of news um on this
from president zielinski zielinski says
in an address to the u.n security
council russia
uh uses veto as a weapon um yuan's
system must be transformed he said that
the u.n has failed to provide security
in the world and called for reforming
the organization restoring strength of
the u.n charter so he's calling out the
u.n here yeah for the security that they
have not provided for ukraine and i
think he's kind of referring to
uh the
atrocity that is in bucha but really
honestly the
the
the [ __ ] genocide is one thing but
then russia trying to manipulate their
citizens into believing right that it
was ukrainians that did the genocide
yeah um not only
it just
it it has this hint
of what would happen in this country if
we had a murderous dictator take over
and fox news newsmax and oan
were were their news agencies it really
it really does seem like [ __ ] tucker
carlson would simp for a murderous
dictator here
like like uh they are
for putin i mean they've already got you
know they you know they're ready to go
rock you know lock stock and barrel they
got their uh their their propaganda
machine you know whenever something goes
you know whenever something's you know
trending the wrong way they'll come in
and obviously you know as rachel says
there's a strategic strategic outrage
that's done in the opposite effect which
is to say like oh guys don't look over
here look at this thing that the
democrats are doing right now god forbid
it's the thing that actually helps you
like you know uh an aid package or
uh health care or something that
actually would benefit your your your
well-being as opposed to oh we're gonna
you know
uh complain and [ __ ] about something
that doesn't
you know doesn't matter at all well
we're gonna take away people's liberty
so much so that if we and and we're
gonna lie about it and so much so that
if we commit genocide we just might lie
about it too so don't don't think what
what is happening in ukraine is isolated
to ukraine it is happening in ukraine
because there's a murderous maniac a
dictator who is a [ __ ] butcher who
loves genocide and who loves to kill
people who are pro-democracy
democracy isn't perfect we've said that
a million times here and it isn't and it
won't be for a long time i don't know if
democracy will ever be perfect that's
kind of the [ __ ] point right it's an
evolution point that's right rowing it's
an or yeah that's kind of just like just
like the constitution is the living
document the thing changes that's it
make amendments that's it you know just
protect it the right wing
amendment's past the first and second
you know right yeah anything from those
forget what it is who knows right well
you you brought up rachel bittikover you
guys know that we have rachel on here
and gabe i think you got to jump but
right after this break right out there's
this break we will we oh did she she's
saying no no no she's saying oh no she's
gonna she's like oh no he's leaving
that's why oh well oh oh i thought [ __ ]
oh okay i got you yeah yeah no it's not
about you tony not about you gabe's yeah
well you know it is it is
uh okay i i get it i see how it works
i'm gonna let it game it no i'm just
kidding gabe i think you got to jump
we're going to bring rachel on we're
going to talk a little more about uh the
genocide that happened in bucha and um
and some of the messaging coming out of
russia and why it is so important to
stay focused on this and i want to show
rachel gabe before we jump did you see
the video of them protesting tucker
carlson and this kind of the ukrainians
um protesting tucker carlson in this
country
it's a fantastic video if you get a
chance come back we'll watch this part
of the show i'll try to send it to you
in a dm i'm going to show rachel that
everyone stick around we have the great
political strategist rachel bittikoffer
right after this message
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dears tammy by the time we reach dc we
was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim gems
skull
near run out natty light hope it don't
rain tomorrow so we can circle the city
again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
oh boy we have we have president
zielinski um
addressing the u.n security council
with important world stuff
and we also have the world famous badass
mofo it looks like she is good thank you
rachel rachel bittikoffer rachel
political strategist rachel bitgover how
are you
i am feeling feeling it tony how are you
oh yeah well you know um we just came
off me and gabe were talking i think you
heard us talking there about the
um the atrocities that happened in
ukraine and um not only that but the
the actual propaganda that russia this i
mean the murderous genocide
um
is one
huge tremendous level that this the
world should look at putin and say you
are a war criminal
and um it's it your days are numbered
and an ammo sandwich is probably
um in your in your current uh future and
diet um but
i would imagine
that
the despicable act of trying to convince
the russian people
that that not that it didn't happen that
it was all faked and ukrainians actually
killed people
um
it has this just this this
this hint and taste
of what it would be like in this country
if fox news
oan
and newsmax were to propagate for a
murderous dictator
and i'm not saying that's not a
possibility because
you know we do have the 2022 midterms
coming up and they're very important
races and we have the 2024 race coming
up after that
and it seems as if the cheeto dust
mobster grapple poopy pants donald
trumps himself is interested in a
possible run
he's definitely throwing all in for
these midterms
what what can we do
in this country to make sure the
atrocity that has happened in ukraine
because folks out there listening they
think oh well that's just that's over
there right that's somewhere else that's
not here
telling you
i'm telling you they're at our doorstep
the same people we just watched the
video me and gabe just watched a video
where there was a woman at a trump rally
and the question was ask her would you
rather have a president vladimir putin
or president joe biden and without
hesitation she's like oh no no no
question
putin
putin
what what is your response to what's
happening in ukraine and and really the
response around the world that is being
given and i want to play a video here of
of the president of ukraine but give us
give us your take on this yeah tony i'm
really glad that um you know it's here
we are we're over a month in okay and
what i said is that you know we've got
this problem because we've got some
segment of right-wing media's ecosystem
devoted to propping up putin and we've
never faced that in uh i mean we've had
division during wartime back in the days
when that you know before the sedition
acts you couldn't be too publicly um
divisive about war stuff and i'm not
saying that that's what we need to go
back to or aspire but it certainly has
never happened in american history where
we haven't we have to run against a not
an insignificant chunk of our own modern
media system and it's not just that
russia is arguing hey these this is all
staged the ukrainians put this out to
gin up support what where what what
they're going to able be able to show on
russian state tv is people like tucker
carlson
buffering the argument
right right right sipping for it simply
and so i sent out a tweet yesterday and
i and you know it it might seem alarmist
and chicken little but the fact of the
[ __ ] matter is that's exactly the
future they have planned for us and we
know it because they already told us so
when they put out the plan before 2020
to round up all their opponents and send
them the guantanamo bay or
i mean jesus christ clarence thomas's
wife was tweeting mark meadows the chief
of staff this stuff
yes
exactly so like i mean here's the thing
i i like to think i'm good at strategy
for a few reasons but one of them is
because like i adapt to changing
conditions on the ground and i don't
suffer from like delusions of status quo
stability right
and you know none of the [ __ ] that's
happened
is [ __ ] that people would have thought
could happen a few years ago and so i
asked and and these red lines that the
republican party has blown right through
right through they didn't even look at
them okay so it's not even like they
agonized over blowing them so why in the
[ __ ] are people so confident that none
of this [ __ ] can happen right we were
right we're living in this world that's
in so impossible to believe you couldn't
sell the script to hollywood 10 years
ago right
so yes i actually do think that they're
positioning themselves quite nicely for
when they do consolidate power and then
of course you know
to jump away from
hyperbole it's not like the day after
they win they're gonna just round people
up guys that's not how that [ __ ] worked
in nazi germany even i mean well look
how long it's taken putin to come i mean
he's been wanting to commit genocide in
ukraine for some time now and here we
are here we are exactly so like it's not
like we're gonna have them take over
control and suddenly everyone's gonna
know that we've fallen into gilead okay
and it's gonna be very it's gonna vary
between the the control they wrangle
from congress to the presidential cycle
but if they control the three statewide
offices of michigan wisconsin and uh
pennsylvania you're talking about the
secretary of state or oh no i'm talking
about the governors the secretary of
state if they own the if they own those
state governments yeah and and right now
with the models picking up you know the
republican party is going to clean house
as of today the lecture was held today
with all this [ __ ] going on
all of it they would win
and and if they win they're probably
going to flip at least a couple of those
three and without them we don't have a
free and fair 24. so you know although i
do um
really
bemoan my un
um you know scheduled like um role of of
of being hey this shit's coming and we
we need to thwart it we need to treat it
seriously we need to panic before the
crisis emerges you know i i know i have
to do it because i can see exactly where
we're headed
well i mean even outside uh
these these gqp weirdos
wanting to be
be putin themselves rather be trump
desantis or any any of these other uh
pro-putin uh gqpr's they are
and it is amazing to me
that you're saying that they're poised
to win they're passing don't say gay
bills in florida and they're passing
marry a child bill in tennessee they
literally are passing bills to where it
allows grown men to marry children and
they're branding us as pa as a part of
the profiles so like that so i'm so you
know that's why we can't try to get
people to understand like this whole
[ __ ] with judge brown is not a vacuum
this is a brand that they're trying to
justify
are
what whatever might come that they
choose to do the opposition and they're
doing that by defining all of us i [ __ ]
you not as child predators pedophiles or
pedophile enablers okay
and as stupid as that is it's [ __ ]
stupid guys i promise you it is working
and they're only just now really getting
getting it out of that 25
and into the other 25 percent of their
coalition
right so
and
we talked about this last week i believe
is that the don't say gay bill down in
florida and i think there's a lot of um
as bad as it may sound good things that
democrats can learn
from that bill down in florida and what
i mean by this is that the thing that
they're pissed off about because they
won the policy they signed the bill as
far as it is right now in florida that
seven pages of garbage is law in florida
because
the pro-putin dictator though putin
wannabe ron desantis signed that bill
into law
now the one bill we didn't hear about is
the bill out of utah that the governor
vetoed that only affected four children
four children and he even said in his
statement there is no way i'm signing a
bill that makes four people on this in
my state only four people make them feel
bad about who they are there's no way
i'm signing this bill and the legislator
overturned it they won that policy but
democrats didn't win the messaging in
utah they won the messaging in florida
and here's why i say that is because
republicans in the comments out there
these these [ __ ] trolls these bots
what they're saying what they're mad
about when we post stuff about don't say
gay isn't about the law they don't care
about the law they don't care that
republicans are the ones who are
sexualizing gender especially children's
gender they're sexualizing children's
gender with these laws
what they're mad about is that democrats
successfully branded it don't say gay
yeah they literally are [ __ ]
infuriated they're like it doesn't
expect
people like every time i'm like so when
i hit them with [ __ ] that they do to us
flipped around against them weaponized
against them which was of course the
guiding vision of what i wanted to do
um they [ __ ] their [ __ ] pants because
they understand the power of it right
michael steele like a year ago was
tweeting man you guys ought to check out
rachel back up for holy [ __ ] right
because they know
it's powerful and when we
deploy their own tactics against them
and [ __ ] them up like we did with don't
say gay down in florida it r you could
they did you know what here's the thing
their whole response though was like
what how we usually act right we'll go
read the bill it doesn't say that
there's nothing right exactly
there's no line item there's no line
item right
prove it to me re read the bill read the
bill you know all this [ __ ] that they
say but we can do this we can do this on
every front it doesn't just right that
bill like this new intensity what they
look like when they're defensively
because like if you if you launch an
attack right which is their whole
[ __ ] system
the person's inclination is to respond
to the attack okay
and we're so stupid we jump we love it
we're like oh let's have a [ __ ]
substantive debate dude let's let me let
me get my pile of statistics that you
don't give a [ __ ] about oh my god let me
get that [ __ ] love it and they know
it right so like okay these morons well
like i i i mean you watch democratic
politicians candidates
strategists whoever they go out in these
public interviews and they think it's
about having an honest conversation
about substance
right and the gop is like no it's about
[ __ ] winning the message dude right
they go out there with a with a media
strategy to win the interview
right because because we've said this so
many times is that there's two things
that are at work here and liberals
and democrats don't understand this
there is there is government there is
policy and then there is politics
there's elections and you don't get to
do the whole government thing or the
policy thing if you don't do the
politics and win elections like you
don't they're two separate things
government and politics are not the same
they're not the same they don't live in
the same universe and republicans
understand that not only republican
politicians but the constituents
understand that now that you get to say
whatever you want and it doesn't have to
be real right like right like these
people don't believe half the [ __ ]
they're saying they just understand from
their propaganda that that's how we win
yep going exactly right i mean the whole
[ __ ] party is strategic
right
like and then they only have one mission
it's not to cure racism and promote
diversity and make sure union shops are
used and no one is underpaid they give
they don't give a [ __ ] about any of that
what the gop values is winning roi win
that's the only return on investment
that matters over there right and we're
up against that and we're already
showing that if we deploy good strategy
against them it [ __ ] panics the [ __ ]
out of them so we should be doing it at
every turn and there is no place easier
to napalm um politically than the state
of florida right the state of florida
and now the state of tennessee because
there's also another despicable bill at
tennessee where a family member um can
sue uh uh someone who has an abortion
who has been raped by their family
member oh my gosh and if i'm working in
the ads and this is the problem like our
groups don't have the balls to air this
[ __ ] right but if i'm making i do i
don't if i'm dealing with abortion like
i don't i'm not gonna focus on
reproductive freedom and [ __ ] we [ __ ]
dude i'm gonna show
one of these poor women who've been
raped who talks about having to share
be forced to have a baby forced to share
custody with your rapist right i mean
it's a [ __ ] horrifying thought and
all you have to do is personalize it in
a way that makes moms and young women
see themselves and their kids in it
so let me let me play let me go back and
rewind just a bit i do want to play
a clip here and i i i haven't reviewed
this clip but it is a clip from the
united nations of president zielinski um
addressing them let's listen to what he
has to say it's about a minute long we
have proven that we help others not only
happy time but in dark times too and now
we need decisions from the security
council for peace in ukraine if you do
not know how to uh
to make this decision you can do two
things either remove russia as an
aggressor
and a source of war
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own war
and then do everything that we can
do
uh to establish peace or the other
option is please show how we can
uh
reform or change dissolve yourself and
and work for peace or i mean this is um
he's calling the u.n out on the rug here
um rightfully so by making sure that
that uh vladimir putin
in a way can't vote for his own
pass on genocide um
and
folks if you're listening
you you think that you have your fuzzy
little job in your cute little community
and your great little church and all the
little sports that you go to on the
weekends with your kids
ukrainians don't have that
it's gone it's gone in the middle of an
eye right
within within a week and now we're we're
four weeks into this guy i didn't tony
and didn't think it was gonna happen 12
hours before with 180 russians lined up
at the border still could not accept
that it was coming
don't tell me
when i that i'm get that i'm
out of control and being ridiculous when
i say that this can happen in our
country i'm telling you vladimir putin
had the power to invade ukraine
yeah and regardless of why and what nato
and u.n and and obviously
president zielinski has a lot of beef
here and he has a lot of um names he
wants to take and asses he wants to kick
probably for the genocide that happened
in ukraine
but
we are in a situation with the gop
who are showing you who they are they're
telling you hey
we love putin and we want that type of
[ __ ] here we want to be able to just
eradicate anyone we don't like because
putin does that and we think he's tough
because he does that we think
average americans like this this uh
tuned out class so you have to force
them to look they're not going to seek
the information out and then you have to
force them to look at a way they can't
turn their eyes hit pause go to the
bathroom whatever right and what we have
to [ __ ] force them to accept is that
at these trump rallies there are people
who are like [ __ ] putin
and then we call them republican rallies
not trump rallies right i call them nazi
rallies yeah well they are right right
yeah i mean there's not get not getting
around it much but you know
uh let me show you um the video
uh one of the videos from the trump
rally i can put up here real quick that
we watched earlier but it's worth
watching again because i think it's
absolutely [ __ ] terrifying yeah this
is this is terrifying to me to me it is
yeah this is the good liars and he just
asks looks like some chick that lives in
your neighborhood dude maybe walks by
with her kids and her dog
this person might be yours
your child's school teacher no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] or your doctor
she may be the one protecting your
children she may be the one who is
asking your children about the sexuality
of their gender she may be asking your
children what books that her parents
read to them because they want to ban it
they want to find out if their parents
are liberal
they want to find out if if child
protective services should be come to
your home and take not just you to jail
but your children away because maybe
just maybe you have some question your
child has some question
about their identity this could be that
[ __ ] person listen to this person who
would you rather have president joe
biden or vladimir putin oh putin
holy [ __ ] rachel
like
not even not even like um she's like oh
oh 100
putin baby bladdy daddy is my guy
now
i don't know
if she has done her own research but my
guess is
is that she is a tucker carlson fan
that's my guessing dude yeah i'm
guessing i'm guessing
tony right i don't think i'm far up
there let's listen to what else she says
because it gets more disturbing as it
goes definitely
and and what and why is that um i
believe he's been given a tough uh
since since world war ii uh rush has
been the bad guy jesus when in actuality
the nazis left germany
and they ended up going to the ukraine
coming in here george bush was actually
thank you george bush was actually a
nazi i'm not sure which one she's
talking about can you figure that out is
she talking about hw or she just lumping
them both together as george bush i mean
it is some wacky [ __ ] i'm not a george
just h.w bush it is wacky though but
like here let me explain this go ahead
go ahead all right and i and this is to
everyone really right
these people look [ __ ] functionally
moronic okay but they're actually very
shrewd and what's happening when i see
that i realize this is like the the um
the canary and the coal mine
warning system the [ __ ] nuts that
they can interview on the sidelines of
these trump events because they are the
types that are digesting
lots of right-wing media and that [ __ ]
usually gets seated in the old web and
then comes up to fox where then he gets
picked up by our mainstream media
because we can't resist right so um
what you heard there is is this and this
is something that i think plays into
this potential future that i'm working
hard to avoid for america
the justification
that she provides is actually
putin's a good guy because the nazis
left and they infiltrated ukraine his
operation therefore in ukraine is about
fighting fascism okay
now that is all intentional gaslighting
it's like calling your election stealing
bill the election integrity thing that's
modus operandis on the right okay
but then she goes and explains how
fascism went from there to here so when
they come for us people i want you guys
to understand what they're going to do
is they are going to categorize us as
fascists right because they know that
that's what we're going to call them and
they want to blunt the effect of that
attack by putting a bunch of cloud or
confusion in the minds of people as to
what everybody's a fascist no one is
right which is which wouldn't be a
problem in a rhetorical fight like we
used to have in the 90s but this is not
the 1990s they are actual fascists right
you can't have power to that
then it's going to be a huge problem and
you can you're going to see what she was
talking about this fringe convo three
months two months from now is going to
start to sound much more mainstream as
it took a year for this pedophile
[ __ ] right well that's the same
thing as as marjorie taylor green saying
romney murkowski and and susan collins
are pro-pedophile because they voted for
uh catanji brown jackson because she was
a federal judge and she had to sentence
people who participated in child lasting
and pedophilia right in order to win
politics the gop the most of it all but
three was willing to brand the first
african-american supreme court justice
you know
as a [ __ ] child predator okay
like that's who we're up against guys
there and they weren't scared of it not
only that they were they were they
weren't frightened to whine about how it
was so unfair that the white guy brett
kavanaugh had to answer questions about
sexual um assault allegations that were
against him and why
why katanji brown jackson didn't have to
answer because there's none against her
they whined about it and they said see
it's unfair unfair that white people are
treated unfairly especially white men
and women who have a religion because
they did that nonsense too i mean that's
all comes right out of the goebbels and
pre-early nazi party
you know as it was rolling up past the
push and into the real power you know um
the parliamentary power path this is the
[ __ ] that they did dude right right
because they created a whole new
moralism right so like i can't remember
exactly how it was described but if you
can take them if you can take morality
and pervert it enough where you know the
victims of racism are the racists right
right like we really are
not far from when people will get
rounded up if they have the power to do
so and they already have done it to
hunter biden guys now hunter biden may
or may not have committed some white
collar crimes right
and if he did like you know i could give
two flying [ __ ] about hunter biden
right because i believe in the rule of
law one way or the other but the fact of
the [ __ ] matter is hunter biden would
never be getting investigated there's
only one political investigation
happening in america right now and it's
the one in hunter biden right right
right he was singled out by the virtue
of being related to the guy they wanted
to beat for president and they have
suck the the weight of the federal
government investigation wise well not
only that the [ __ ] media the media
well
because here's the here's the craziest
new development if you want to call it
that in the hunter biden laptop story
number one
americans are allowed to own laptops
they're allowed to email from laptops
now rather they commit crime or not
that's up to the justice department fbi
but the latest story is that these
right-wingers are so pissed off that
hunter biden
that the federal government has to pay
30 000 to protect him because they're
[ __ ] threatening his life
what you [ __ ] weirdos
you just and but that's their intention
and speaking
people right [ __ ] out the gate like
hey if we take control of the house
we're gonna abuse our power and come
right after you guys regardless of the
law right you know what it is like i
mean they're standing in front of
microphones and saying it
speaking of speaking of speaking the
microphones speaking of people who speak
the the the quiet pirate out loud in the
microphones tucker carlson is really
good at this gerbil stuff because he he
asks questions like was putin never hurt
you has he ever has he ever uh taken
your children out of school has he ever
made your children wear masks has he
ever ate dogs i don't know where that
came from but but this weird ass [ __ ]
that he does these questions because
that's part of the slow drip drip drip
is not just to tell people that putin's
good is to say well what has putin done
bad for you and if putin isn't bad to
you then he must be good then the
alternative must be true right right if
he isn't bad for you he must be good for
you but here's here is i want to show
this video
this is uh i believe down
in florida i'm not sure exactly where
this report is but this is ukrainian
americans
um and they're protesting outside what i
believe is a church against tucker
carlson um let's show this real quick
this news report
ukrainian american demonstrators lined
outside of awakened church in protest
against controversial fox news guest
speaker tucker carlson your heartless
message
to american people
who are the cradle of democracy
home of the brain brave
land of the free is completely
unacceptable by anyone they are blasting
carlson for his recent comments on
russia they say he spreads pro-russia
propaganda protesters say these
strollers car seats and babies shoes
represent the 150 plus children killed
by the war in ukraine a lot of victims
of this vicious war are actually
children just last week we had over 300
children that perished in this war lost
their lives but this week is much much
more we cannot even quantify
church-goers here say they support the
protesters freedom of speech but
disagree
so this next part is an interview of a
woman who who steps for tucker carlson
is absolutely
weird and to watch
to watch her face
to have to to have to try
to swallow the murder and genocide that
she knows what putin's doing she knows
this but to swallow that and descent for
tucker is really [ __ ] gross and don't
and this is proof
proof that it won't take any time at all
for them to do in ukraine here in this
country watch i've been watching tucker
for
quite a while now and i just feel
his viewpoints are
you know
spot on he needs to change
his viewpoints
are spot-on and if you look if you look
at the face of that woman and you tell
me that she is not thinking in the back
of her head
how do i say this on the news without
appearing to
support genocide of children but she
does anyways yep she does anyway
and it's exactly what you were saying
let's see
we're leaving something really important
on address here yes go ahead
why in the [ __ ] is tucker carlson
speaking at a woke church
you know i guess i guess that is a good
point um
again i'm not sure what the story is
behind this protest i'm just i'm just
glad to see
that not only the protest is happening
but what it's doing is prompting
reporters to put microphones in front of
average america's faces and making them
on tv in front of a microphone explain
why they're pro genocide
why they are anti-democracy in this
country because that's what the
ukrainian americans said you piece of
[ __ ] tucker carl i mean if i could say
so many words you peacha [ __ ] tucker
carlson are anti-democracy you are
simping for putin who wants to destroy
democracy not just in ukraine but around
the world so he can remain in power
because democracy the idea just simply
the idea
is putin's enemy because the idea of
democracy just the same not not the
actual policy or or the actual act of
democracy the idea of democracy is his
[ __ ] enemy because it will destroy
him if people in russia discover oh
if we want the things that we want
democracy will deliver it to us not a
murderous dictator let's finish up this
clip and then we'll comment to show to
the public and to the world and to
himself that he's for life four humans
four people and he has empathy and
decency as a human being to take a right
side so i guess that's that's the ending
there the the dismount is that uh tucker
carlson and shame on rupert murdoch fox
news and anyone who carries the fox news
channel out there for him simping for
putin i i'm not again i i'm not for just
you know turning off fox news and and
biden signing executive order to get rid
of this i'm for free speech i believe
you have the right to be stupid in this
country i believe you had the right to
be a fascist you absolutely have the
right to harbor those despicable [ __ ]
ideas but here's the thing
when you act it out and you and you yell
fire
in a crowded theater it is no longer
free speech it's not
when you're when when your actions and
your words
are not only not only affecting
americans but affecting lives around the
world you are culpable well here's a
wild and crazy thing tony that i don't
think other people like people know you
know it you know in in the uk france
canada italy whatever all these other
[ __ ] places where they they have free
speech right but they what they don't
have what they don't have
is this weird [ __ ] up ideology that
emerged over years uh for
reasons that are obvious to
pervert our rule of law okay by by
locking like this entire ideology of
originalism or dead constitution is
really grounded in that what we don't
have what they don't have what we do
have
is militancy like in terms of the first
amendment the second amendment um the
first amendment does not give us or
people a license to be put you know put
on the public airways or you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want it's about
it's the amplified amplification
of [ __ ] that is
questionable right and in other
immediate environments that you can't
call [ __ ] news that isn't news right
right
well even in court even in court fox
news and tucker carlson made the
argument in open court that they're
entertainment it's not really news he's
entertainment which is kind of crazy and
back to the here's a good analogy that i
always use for the first amendment
so you have the right to stand because
walmart is a really famous um
american company right everyone knows
whose walmart is you have the right to
stand on the public sidewalk in front of
walmart out off their property and to
hold a sign that says walmart [ __ ]
sucks you have that right as an american
you do not have the right however you do
not have the right however to walk on
their property and spray paint on the
side of their building walmart [ __ ]
sucks without consequence you can do
that you can go do that but you can't do
it without consequence and so that's the
thing that these morons get freedom of
speech all wrapped up and they they
don't understand
that of what it actually is and that's
where it gets uh
you know it's the government doesn't
can't censor political speech okay right
exactly but at the end of the [ __ ]
day fox is not a governmental entity
it's a it's a private sector thing right
uh the act of of saying whatever the
[ __ ] i want to make money
is is um is you know at the end of the
day the platforms that my messages is uh
put on the advertisers the you know the
the studios that hire me the shows the
cape whatever all of that completely
unfucking protected by the first
amendment mm-hmm
well
and i i
here's the problem with the the gqp in
the first two amendments they can't get
past those two like it's they they love
that the constitution is not a living
document even though they don't know the
amendments or changes to the document um
that they claim that can't be changed
but they they don't understand the first
one they don't understand the second one
and that's the last amendment that they
can
harbor in their brains
and i always appreciate you rachel
coming on the show and breaking down
things and i'm glad we got to talk a
little more
about um what is happening in russia and
ukraine and i want to remind the
listeners and even you tomorrow um aaron
parnez is going to be on the show he's
going to be talking about some of the
stuff in ukraine um he has family in
ukraine so he has some special insight
into it so he's gonna give us some
updates but he's really been keeping
track of all the updates all the news um
so if anyone has any questions for aaron
tomorrow tag me
at the tonymichaels on twitter i will
try to collect those and make sure with
it or come to the chat tomorrow because
um we're not gonna let i'm not gonna let
this ukraine stuff go i'm not gonna let
the january six uh select committee
stuff go and um
so tomorrow we're going to definitely
ask aaron about the conflict in ukraine
and before we before we cause we got a
few minutes here rachel because i always
appreciate you joining us before we go
speaking of the january 6th select
committee did you see
that there's there's been some talk and
it's it doesn't seem that it's official
that it seems like the january 6 select
committee is not going to be giving
criminal referrals have you heard this
have you heard this news
and um a lot of people are freaking out
but um i'm with uh mueller she wrote on
this um i think i believe she tweeted
let's see if i can find it um she
tweeted that
that um
it actually is not a bad thing if the
january 6 select committee is actually
not going to think that they need to
give criminal referrals because what the
thought is is that if we don't need to
give credible referrals that means the
department of justice is already on
those referrals now i have faith in our
justice system um i think at this point
though i'm with a lot of people that
merrick garland um should stand up and i
think president biden has said it in
private i believe that merrick garland
needs to stand and he needs to stand on
the side of of law and order in this
country and there's enough uh evidence
in public that he can start to
go after what we would think of as the
top of the tier um in this coup plot
what is your opinion on the january 6th
select committee and the doj at this
point in mayor garland where are you at
in that situation
tony like you i have a lot of confidence
in the rule of law prevailing here and
the reason is is because it has to if it
doesn't happen if there's not criminal
proceedings to deal with the fact that a
one of our two political parties plotted
against all three branches of government
and across multiple states with
multi-state parties
to overthrow the government
that is not the kind of thing that you
can just say well
it's bad politics you know we can't
investigate torture eight years after
you know whatever this is like this is
it's such a given to me that we're gonna
see
legal ramifications for these coup
plotters who wish to take over power and
then continue their plots against the
government and if it doesn't happen tony
then it will be cat a [ __ ] clistic
and i'm not going to sugarcoat it right
one i i think that's important let me
show the tweet here
from mueller she wrote she says i think
news that the 1-6 committee is now
leaning towards not in capital letters
making criminal referrals is because
we've learned doj is investigating the
tippy top of the coup so there's no need
to politicize it by making the referral
the committee may have thought doj was
waiting for the referral i actually so i
agree with part of this i disagree with
part of this here's the part i disagree
with i actually believe and i
i think it's the truth is that
republicans
made their bet that a political
investigation would be the best
investigation and that's why they didn't
want a january 6th select committee all
right excuse me a 911 style commission
like we have for 911. they would have
worked out great if it wasn't for those
two meddling kids right exactly
right
and if but if we if we would have gotten
the 911 commission i actually think it
would be better for republicans now that
we know what we know
but they wanted it to be political right
and i believe that's what the january 6
select committee is is a political
investigation because it is inside
the house
i also believe that because it's
political
um and maybe the gen 6 select committee
know certain things
that they're going to wait at the
opportune time to make sure the american
people know
everything they need to know about what
they need to know about at the most
opportune time with this 2022 midterm
and everyone's gonna say oh my god
they're you mean they're making it
political that's what the republicans
wanted and i believe they miscalculate
so often they overextend their
confidence so often that that is exactly
what they did they miscalculated they
thought that they could win this
political battle and they could push it
well past the midterms they could take
the house and they could bury this
investigation and what i think they
miscalculated on was that liz cheney
absolutely 100 percent as undemocratic
as she is and as much of a hero as she
may be which i don't think she's a hero
for democracy she voted against voting
rights
but her goal is to take back her party
and to bury trumpism for good and let me
tell you
i remember on the anniversary of
of january 6 there were two republicans
two prominent republicans that stood
with nancy pelosi to remember that day
and it was liz cheney
and her father
darth vader dick cheney
america that's right any other [ __ ]
republican except for too
here's the thing tony you're absolutely
right it was a strategy we're going to
not do
i mean number one they understood they
could not [ __ ] investigate january 6
without it doing all the way back to
meadows
mccarthy they were implicating
themselves their entire state party
apparatus they [ __ ] knew what they
were covering up and their decision to
not only tank the committee but to lobby
the tank it that is a [ __ ]
unprecedent i mean imagine that [ __ ] in
in any country reading that headline and
you'd be like wow that country's fallen
into a banana republic
nuts right but that but they
miscalculated
liz [ __ ] cheney and attitude
and at the end of the day tony like
you're this faith that the timing's
gonna be good for politics and all of
that
like i'd have zero faith in that if it
wasn't for the fact that liz cheney's in
charge of that [ __ ] and right because
she wants she has more she has more
political she has more uh uh uh to gain
in the politics of it than anyone on the
january 6 select committee i think i
don't think that motivates her though i
think what motivates her is that she is
at the end of the day an
institutionalist who loves america okay
and you can say what you want about the
other [ __ ] but at the end of the [ __ ]
day what liz cheney has done is she she
is is absolutely extraordinary
and the select committee's efficacy so
far to me
is a product of the republican
mind
running the committee right in a way
that is but here's what i would leave
people at as i'm i'm moving into this
free agency uh gig that i've set up for
myself
at the end of the day cheney and
kissinger are used to working with a
republican party though right so like
they're used to pitching the ball and
someone's swinging right having fox news
and [ __ ] swing right having having
the apparatus uh project their message
and propagating exactly
what i'm working hard to try to get
people to help let me help put in place
because at the end of the day
when i said we have to make
regular america look i [ __ ] mean it
they can put those hearings right in the
middle of prime time it ain't 1990 okay
there's so much media choice few people
will still watch it many republican
leaning independents will avoid it like
the plague so that they can get tucker
carlson to tell them a false version of
what happened in it that's exactly how
they managed last two impeachment
processes it's not like these people
assess the evidence and then they're
like ah [ __ ] it they like a lot of them
won't [ __ ] look like they're like
they look at where they know they need
to look that's exactly right they
because cause their comfort blanket is
fox news oa and newsmax and tucker
carlson in that they'll tell me what i
want to hear about the the actual stuff
that's out there they'll spin it so that
i can go to my work and spin it for tom
yeah and karen and i can write and i can
make sure that i have my talking points
the day that the big headlines about
giuliani sitting in that restaurant in
ukraine talking about the big plot to
extort the president on himself at the
day that that broke in the impeachment
trial which was a major [ __ ] news day
okay even in these standards it was a
big [ __ ] news day i went and i
listened to right wing radio uh and
people like so what happened today in
the impeachment trial well it was it was
a bad day for hunter b
right hunter biden's laptop is going to
release a message later describing why
it's in trouble tell the audience what
happened no why would they right well
and that's
um and i think i think um
you know a lot of people don't
understand how right wing media work and
we me and you have talked a lot about
this on the show and in private and i
have listened to right wing talk radio a
lot
in my former days i i again i don't i
vehemently disagree with him but i
watched how they did it and i watched
how they did it and how they pound the
drum and you're completely correct and i
think that's why we get along so well is
because we understand that there are two
different things there is government and
policy and instituting policy and
there's politics and winning elections
so rachel thanks for joining us i'm so
glad we get to cut out with
rachel bittikoffer dr rachel bittikoffer
the political strategist formerly
formally with strike back now a
political strategist in her own
what what what what are can you describe
i'm actually calling myself an ad
slinger for hire right now an ad slinger
for hire
any anyone out there looking for
political ads to sling uh
not just any political ad right what's
the matter really it's got to be the
best one it's about the messaging
revolution the strategic right why run
against us when we could run against
them that's it
that's it thank you rachel for joining
us and audience don't forget to join us
tomorrow at noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific youtube twitter twitch and now
on the minus touch facebook page don't
forget to join us every single weekday
monday through friday and until tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's mealborn had asked